- What's the most--
- Hold on, shut up.
- This is important.
(mellow music)
(record skips)
- [Connor] It's a small,
little, mid-sized case.
Everything should fit snugly in there.
Get this shit off of here.
(Joey gasps)
- [Connor] Take that out of here.
(Joey yells)
- Hello, welcome to a Trash
Taste speed run PC build stream.
- We don't know who's going to go first
with building the PC.
- Trash (mumbles) will discover that.
- Trash (mumbles), but in the meantime,
while Joey shakes that thoroughly.
We should thank the
providers of this stream,
thank you Gigabyte AORUS
for providing us with
(mumbles) of 3090s.
How do you even get those?
They make them, I'm pretty
sure they don't even have them,
so thank you for getting them,
we're going to be building those today.
And Joey, do you wanna do the honors
and find out who's going first today?
- Okay.
- I hope Joey goes first.
- Yeah.
- Because Joey doesn't
know how to build a PC.
- Joey's never build a PC before.
A week ago Joey didn't know
that this was motherboard,
he thought this was a CPU.
- Even though it says motherboard.
- It says motherboard right there.
- All right, here we go,
our first person is...
Garnt.
- Oh okay, all right.
It's early morning, I'm fine with that.
- I literally haven't woken up yet.
Guess I'm going to be
building first, brilliant.
Are you guys ready?
Let me do a Connor right now.
(Garnt grunts)
(group laughs)
Come on Garnt, wake up.
All right.
- [Navi] Time in three.
Two.
One.
Go.
- [Joey] Let's go.
- The first thing is the motherboard,
now I'm guessing...
(bell dings)
For fuck sake, this is an empty box.
- [Connor] Off to a good start there.
- [Garnt] Oh shit, I've never installed
this kind of CPU before.
- [Joey] Well, if you haven't
then I'm certainly fucked,
aren't it?
- [Connor] We have an Intel CPU,
and Intel CPUs have a little bit
of annoying mounting cooler.
- For fuck sake Navi.
(loud laughter)
Can you tell me next time.
I'm going to take time out
of my speed run to say,
this is very extra packaging
Intel, I got to say.
Guys.
I've found a problem.
Oh no, because I need to ground myself,
and these are three-pronged.
- [Connor] You'll be all right,
you don't need to ground
yourself, you'll be fine.
So the time will end when their PC boots.
But it has to boot, so if they get...
- [Joey] So, as long as it doesn't boot
that timer is gonna keep on ticking.
- If there's one part I
don't want to fuck up,
it's the CPU.
I really hope I'm putting
this in the right way.
- [Connor] Just wing it.
When was the last time
you built a PC, Garnt?
- Two years ago, I think.
- [Connor] Okay, that's kind of long ago.
- I can kind of remember,
because I remember watching
the Linus tech tips video,
as I'm sure everyone did at one point
when building their first PC.
(Joey and Connor laugh)
(Connor mumbles)
- Where is the M2 supposed to go?
What the fuck?
- [Connor] Garnt is getting stuck
at finding where the drive goes.
- How do I unscrew?
- [Connor] How do I unscrew,
I think we're at a good start.
- Do I have to...
- [Connor] It's on talk, I think,
you have to turn it off talk.
- How the fuck do I turn it off talk.
- [Joey] Installing the CPU, that's fine,
there's a couple of steps to it.
And then immediately it says,
"Installing the CPU cooler."
- [Connor] Yeah.
- [Joey] Did he do that?
- [Connor] No, he (laughs)...
No, he hasn't done that.
- [Joey] Okay, I was gonna say.
- How do I untalk this?
- [Joey] I think he went straight
to the dual channel memory configuration.
- [Connor] He did.
- [Joey] Yeah, okay.
- [Garnt] All right, how do...
- [Connor] How do you...
How do PC go broom?
- [Joey] PC go broom?
- [Connor] How do it work?
- [Garnt] Oh no.
- [Connor] Careful.
Okay, I'm going to tell you this now,
because you will get stuck on it for hours
if I don't tell you.
If you put it up...
No, don't do that, don't
put it on the thermal yet.
If you put it on, you won't
be able to get it off.
And also you don't need
the bottom thermal thing,
the screw isn't big enough
to have both double layers.
Because the top thing has a thermal layer.
- [Garnt] I have a more pressing issue,
which is this end tube
does not fit in this notch.
Oh, I had it the wrong way round.
(Garnt laughs)
- [Joey] Who will win poll,
that is happening right now.
Unsurprisingly, 82% is for Connor.
And Garnt and I are at 9% each.
How do you feel about that Garnt?
- I'm going first, so I feel like...
- [Connor] Yeah, exactly,
it's a little unfair right now
to be doing it this quickly.
- [Garnt] I have to screw this in first,
before I screw that.
- [Connor] (mumbles) To screw that in,
I shouldn't tell you this,
I should let you figure it out, sorry.
- I knew that, where's the screw from it?
Shit.
Let's get that out the way.
- [Joey] Right, the odds,
it's one to 800,000.
- I'm going first and I'm still panicky,
because it's been so long
since I've built a PC
that I don't remember each and every step.
- [Connor] You still at the M2 right now?
- [Garnt] Yes, I am.
- [Connor] You're screwing that in?
- [Garnt] I assume this is
the screw that (mumbles).
- [Connor] it looks like it.
- [Joey] Are they two different screws?
Oh, and then you put
the cover back on top.
- On the last PC I built,
my M2 didn't even have a heat sense.
- [Connor] God, imagine
having an Engineering degree,
it would make this so much easier.
- [Joey] What are you doing?
- Fucking up.
By plastic, did you mean this part?
- [Connor] You gotta peel that off.
- Okay, yeah.
(Connor laughs)
- [Connor] All right.
- All right, I finished
the RAM and M2 drive.
- [Connor] All right, do the
split on the RAM and SSD.
(celebratory toot)
- [Garnt] Sorry, I'm just...
- [Joey] Got that case.
- Getting the case out, oh.
- [Connor] that's a hefty
case you've got there Garnt.
- [Joey] That is a nice case.
- [Connor] Everything
should fit snugly in there.
- I know I'm going to beat Joey,
because he's going to spend half an hour
just peeling off the plastic.
- [Joey] Yeah, I am.
I can't believe you didn't
even savor the peeling,
I'm actually upset.
- Just wait until it's Joey turn,
and you're gonna see him orgasm
from peeling off plastic.
- [Joey] No, I am going slow,
I am going to do peely ASMR on my board.
- [Connor] How are you doing Garnt?
How are you feeling so far?
- [Garnt] Not great, I'm not
going on the case I wish I was,
also this is a really tight fit.
- [Connor] Yeah, the IO
shield is going to be a pain.
- [Navi] Well, it's better
to put that (mumbles) first.
- Oh yeah, fuck.
That means I have to unscrew it.
- [Connor] Garnt's realized
that it's probably better
to take the fan out so he has more space.
You could probably do it but
without taking the fan out,
but it's probably going
to be really annoying.
- [Garnt] It's very tight.
It wasn't this tight when
I built my first one.
- [Connor] 62% of the viewers watching
have not built a PC before.
- [Joey] Okay, that's good, I'm glad,
I'm glad I'm not the only one.
- And now for the time I've been dreading,
because the only thing
I've never done before
is install the water cooler.
So I don't know how to
install a water cooler.
- [Connor] I like the water cooler.
- [Joey] That just sounds like
a disaster waiting to happen.
- [Connor] But it looks fucking
amazing, it's so aesthetic.
- [Joey] It does, but the
concept for having water
near some of the most expensive
electronic I've ever had.
- [Connor] It's contained in a loop.
As long as you're not going in your PC,
Bear Grylls tearing
stuff apart with a knife,
you'll be fine.
(Joey chuckles)
- Oh my fucking God.
- [Connor] It just goes on top
and that's it, it's a brick.
- Navi?
- [Navi] Yes.
- Am I reading this right?
Do I have to install a backplate
on the motherboard which I just installed?
- [Navi] Wait, hold on.
- [Connor] (laughs) Wait, no Gark,
perhaps there's another way
you can figure it out Gark.
- My thinking is, maybe you
don't need a back board,
maybe you do, I'm not sure yet.
- [Connor] You definitely
need a back board.
- If I need a back board...
- [Connor] You definitely do for Intel.
- This back board does
not want to come off.
(back board rattles)
- [Connor] That is not the way you do it.
(chuckles) Oh God.
- [Joey] That was the sound that
old apartments make during an Earthquake.
- [Connor] Yeah that was literally a POV,
you're in a Japanese Earthquake.
- Once I get the water cooler done
I'll be a lot more confident.
Right now I'm swimming without a float,
and I'm lost at sea right now,
and I'm hoping I'm doing the right thing.
But, I don't know if I am.
Is this back brace meant to be wobbly?
Ah.
- [Connor] Oh God.
This is probably the part
where you can easily fuck
up the most, I think.
- [Joey] How so?
- Which way do I put the fans?
Huh.
Fuck.
I'm about to apply thermal paste,
and that's the part where
I don't want to fuck up on.
- [Joey] That's supposed to be tight.
- What fucking screw do I use?
It says use G, G for Garnt.
I'm just going to go by faith now,
and I'm just going to hope it works out.
- [Connor] Pray, pray to Jesus God.
- This is where I pray.
- [Joey] I've heard of
this thermal paste stuff.
- [Connor] Okay.
(Gark laughs)
Okay.
I've heard, word around the grape vine.
- Word around the block is, there's--
- Word around the grape vine
is that there's this thing
called thermal paste.
But I've also heard of people
stressing the fuck out
about thermal paste.
- Yeah, you've got to eat it
before you start building the PC.
- Right.
And you've got shit it out, right?
So it's nice and warm.
- Well, I was building mine,
and it was a pre-applied thermal paste.
And I was stressed out, I wasn't thinking,
I just grabbed the thermal cooler,
and I grabbed the thermal
paste and ruined it all.
Garnt, is it in?
- [Garnt] It is in.
- Hey, nice.
- Are we in?
- [Garnt] Oh, it's tight, yes.
- I think Garnt has done it.
- He's done it.
- Oh my God.
Okay, now--
- Just savor the peeling.
- Wait, when you put the cooler in, right?
There was a peely, right?
- Savor the peely.
- All right,
he successfully got the CPU in.
He needs to now get the...
- The fan.
- Get the fans.
- This is the second part
that I've been dreading.
That looks right.
Can you see me cradling this like a baby?
- I'm pretty sure this
is the exact same way
you'd hold a child.
- [Joey] I think you'd actually
hold a child violently than this.
(Connor laughs)
- [Connor] Violently?
I chose death today.
- It's Connor's first unborn child,
first born child.
- [Connor] Unborn?
- [Joey] Unborn child?
- [Connor] Holy shit.
- Okay guys, guys?
It doesn't go up top.
It does not go up top, does it Navi?
I have just figured this out.
It does not...
- [Joey] Does it not?
- [Connor] Oh,
we'll let him figure it out.
We're not helping him,
because I want this to be--
- I know this doesn't go up top,
because the power socket's right there,
and the fan blocks the power socket.
Therefore it does not go up top.
- [Joey] I'm literally
staring at our streaming PC,
and it's at the top.
- Yeah, so that's nonsense.
Garnt is having a midlife crisis.
- I am.
Okay, if you want to go
to a closeup of why...
- Let's get a close up,
let's get a reaction shot.
- I'm having a midlife crisis.
Okay, so let me explain to you two issues.
One, this fan seems to be
very close to this radiator right here,
that just doesn't seem like a good thing.
Number two, it's blocking...
It's blocking this power socket.
- Why would it be a bad thing
if it's close to the radiator?
Just wondering what your thoughts are.
- [Garnt] Number two, the fan
is blocking this power socket.
So...
Yeah, I dunno.
- Call Linus chat up.
- I'm literally very confused now,
because I assume that that's going to need
to be plugged in, and
the fan is blocking it.
Somehow...
- There is a way you can do this.
- Can you...
- We don't want to spoil it.
- [Garnt] Can I take a wild guess?
- Sure, (mumbles).
- [Garnt] You know what?
I don't know.
- (laughs) I was waiting
for the God-tier guess.
- Yeah, I dunno, plug in
the power socket first?
- There's not enough space.
- All right, there's not
enough space as you said.
- Is that not it?
- Nah, he said there's not enough space,
there's not enough space, so it's his...
Walk us through your process Garnt,
tell us everything that's going on here.
- I can't install this fan
and have whatever power socket...
Powered.
So I'm gonna try and see if I could put
the power socket connectors
in first, and then--
- [Joey] That's what I said.
- [Connor] Almost as if
chat was spamming that.
- [Joey] That's what I said,
I made a good guess.
- Holy shit this is a tight fit,
but it fits.
(Garnt laughs)
It just about fits.
- [Joey] I want to write that down.
- [Connor] Write that down.
- [Garnt] Write that down.
- [Connor] This is Garnt's
masterclass of how to build a PC,
just go through the five stages
of grief and panic at the same time,
Fuck everything up.
Worry that you've done everything wrong
when you've done it right,
you just worry if you've
done it right anyway.
- Okay, so, install fan correctly.
- I'm about to unbox the 3090,
since very few people have this now,
I'm sure this is going
to be the first time
a lot of chat has seen a 3090.
This is going to be the
first time I've seen a 3090,
let's get a close up of this.
- Okay, check this...
- [Garnt] Oh.
- Look at that.
- [Garnt] Oh my...
- What a hefty.
- [Garnt] God.
- Jesus Christ.
- Yeah, that's a big boy.
- [Garnt] Oh Lord, she coming.
(Joey and Connor laugh)
- The (mumbles).
- Yeah, you manhandle that.
- 92% says that the PSU before the GPU.
- Yeah, that's true.
- Okay, noted,
thank you chat, I will write that down.
- The wiring for the power supply.
The power supply is already in,
so I've put the power
supply before the wires.
- [Connor] With the power supply in,
it might be a little difficult
to do all the wiring now.
- Yeah, so...
- [Connor] You might have to
unscrew the power supply, maybe.
Ooh, look at that wiring,
it's like a CSI crime scene in that case.
Look at that, oh God.
- It's fucking cool.
- [Joey] Jesus Christ.
- [Garnt] Ow.
It's all right.
- [Connor] What did you hit?
- [Garnt] I just hit my
knee against the table.
- [Connor] Hopefully we got that in 4K.
- Okay, fuck, I am going
to need to unscrew this.
- [Joey] Garnt, what's happening?
- Remember how I plugged in
some of the power sockets
before I plugged in the radiator.
Now, I have to plug these
into the power supply,
and I don't know what the optimal route
to plug these in are.
- [Connor] This is a yikes way
of doing it, unfortunately.
You may even have to
unscrew the radiator Garnt.
- No.
(group laughs)
- [Connor] He's like, "I'm
not doing that, I refuse."
- I can plug it in.
- [Connor] I would rather
fucking die, than unscrew the radiator.
- Guys, I can plug it in, it's fine.
There's a hole right there,
and I think I plugged the wrong thing in.
This is CPU power supply, isn't it?
Oh no, it's the CPU power
supply, it's the CP power supply.
Oh.
(melancholic music)
- [Joey] What happened?
- I'm going to have to
unscrew the radiator.
(group laughs)
- [Connor] There it is.
- [Joey] You all good Garnt.
- I'm good.
I'm good, I'm good.
- [Joey] Talk us through
your process mate,
talk us through your process.
- I'm screwing the radiator
that I screwed out,
I'm screwing it in again.
- [Connor] He's restarting,
because he's fucked everything up.
- [Joey] The ramblings of a mad man.
- What I'm doing is...
I didn't fuck up, I did
exactly the right thing,
I had the right wires in.
And then I psyched myself out,
thought I had the wrong wires in.
In fact, I didn't have the wrong wires in,
I had the right wires in.
And now, I am screwing back the radiator,
which I didn't need to unscrew.
Did that make any sense?
- [Joey] That sentence
was ten times longer
than it should have been.
- [Connor] What part of the
split has the mental breakdown?
- What the fuck is this?
What the fuck?
What are all these?
Okay, I don't know what
the fuck this gamer PC is,
but whenever I've installed a CPU cooler,
it's only needed one wire.
This has three,
why does this have three wires per fan.
Huh.
Uh huh.
- You sound like the
Minecraft guy that goes "Uh."
- [Garnt] As an electronic Engineer,
it looks like I'm creating
a short circuit, right?
- Probably.
- But, as a kit,
this arrow and this arrow point together,
and they connect in with each other.
There's also a wire here,
which I don't know where to plug in.
That's a...
SOTA cable.
But I don't see a SOTA input at all.
So maybe I just leave that
unplugged, I don't know,
I'll get back to that later, I guess.
I think I'm almost done.
Famous last words.
- Oh, oh, look at it.
Oh Jesus.
(mumbles) Like John Travolta, just...
- [Garnt] I got to take this out anyway.
- [Joey] You couldn't
hear anything I said.
- Oh oh.
- Oh shit, why is it restarting?
Oh shit, okay.
- [Joey] Is it gonna boot?
(drum roll sounds)
- It boots.
- [Kids] Yeah!
- [Joey] Time.
- [Connor] Time.
Time.
- [Navi] Two hours and 38
minutes, and eight seconds.
- [Joey] Nice.
(Garnt whoops)
- Sub three hours.
This is the first time I've built a PC
and it booted up first time.
Literally the first
time it's ever happened.
- [Connor] Pog, let's go.
- Holy shit.
- (mumbles) On this fan, okay,
everything looks like it's working.
The cable management is a war crime,
it's probably the worst cable management
I've ever seen of a PC build.
But that's Garnt's problem to fix.
But it looks good.
- It's working.
- It's functional.
Here's the things guys,
I'm an Engineer, right?
I don't care too much about build quality,
all I really cared
about is that it worked.
And this is why I was a systems Engineer,
I just needed to make sure
that the system worked,
and it worked functional to
the specifications I was given.
And the specifications I was given
was that it booted up to the BIOS.
Therefore, by my standards,
it is a successful build,
and that's all that really
needs to be done for this PC.
- [Connor] The lies we tell ourselves
to make us feel better.
- [Joey] All right, I think I'm ready.
- [Garnt] People are saying Joey's gonna
take four hours, five hours.
- I'm just gonna be happy to get it done.
My bar of expectation is very low.
- [Connor] Are you starting?
- Yeah, fuck it, let's do it.
- [Connor] All right, in three,
two,
one,
go.
(long beep)
- [Garnt] And Joey's started.
Joey, make sure you
don't start with the CPU.
- Don't start with the CPU.
It's all right, I got the motherboard out.
- [Connor] Wait, that's
the CPU, right Joey?
- That's the CPU, that's what
the CPU looks like, all right?
That's the CPU.
- To download more RAM.
(windows tone)
(group laughs)
- Download the RAM first.
- This could be the end
of Joey's run, right?
- This could be it, this
could be the run in (mumbles)
- Right as the beginning of the run.
- Gonna go for a really
difficult clip here,
gotta make sure you line
it up in the right spot.
- [Garnt] Yeah, you're basically holding
over a grand right now.
- [Connor] There should
be an indication there
which orientation it goes.
(Connor chuckles)
- [Garnt] Oh.
Okay, yeah, got it.
- [Connor] Just don't want to risk it.
- [Joey] He's holding a lot in his hands.
- [Connor] Is it fully open?
(Garnt sings suspenseful tune)
- [Joey] What?
- [Connor] Did it feel like it slid in?
- [Joey] It did not.
- [Connor] Okay, I would pull it out.
- [Joey] Oh, this is hurting so much.
- Is it fully open, the metal thing?
- I'm fucking sweating,
are you sweating right now?
I'm sweating right now.
You have two options right now,
you can read the manual,
or you can ask chat.
Which is what I did a lot.
And chat is right on the iPad screen.
- This is a lever?
- [Garnt] If you wanna ask chat.
- What about the...
(applause)
Murota.
Okay, Murota.
(group laughs)
- Everyone clap, yeah.
(applause)
- [Connor] He did it, boys, he did it.
Ladies and gentlemen behold.
- [Joey] That was a let's fucking go.
- [Garnt] Let's fucking go!
- [Joey] Let's fucking go!
Make sure the front end of the lower plate
is under the shorter screw.
Finally, secure the leather
under its retention (mumbles).
Is this supposed to be this tight?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] All the way down.
(celebratory toot)
I think you've done it.
- Has he done it?
- [Joey] Have I done it?
- I think you've done it.
- [Joey] I think I've done it.
- You won't know if you've killed the CPU
until you start the thing.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Is the CPU secure?
(buzzing noise)
- [Joey] It's not moving.
- If you wiggle it around.
- Did he just touch it?
Did he just touch the CPU?
- Let's not talk about that.
- [Joey] You literally just said,
"Make sure it's wiggling around."
So I was like, "How am I gonna check
if it's wiggling around?
I obviously fucking push it around."
- It's fine.
- It's good.
- Okay, so think Joey,
you need to screw it in.
- Think I'm gonna tell you the answer,
think the answer is...
- [Joey] The answer is think.
(loud whispering)
- Oh.
- [Garnt] Chat, the screw
is in the motherboard box.
- [Joey] Is there a screw for this?
- And I knew that.
Yeah, there is a screw for that.
And he has to find the screw
in the motherboard box.
- [Joey] Wait, it's inside
the motherboard box?
What did you say?
No, that's not it.
Guys, we're live, can you talk.
(loud laughter)
- [Garnt] Sorry Joey.
- Jesus Christ,
you are terrible entertainers over there.
(Connor laughs)
- [Connor] This is great entertainment.
- [Garnt] I don't know about you chat,
but I feel like our commentary
would just ruin this moment right now.
- [Connor] Yeah, let him
find out, let him find it.
- Inside the box, look in the box.
- [Connor] Yeah.
All right Joey, what are you looking for?
- I don't know, Garnt's
telling me to check the box.
- Oh okay.
(Garnt cheers)
- [Garnt] You think you got it?
- [Joey] I think that's good.
Everything's screwed
in, I think that's good.
Now the case.
(ding)
- [Connor] Oh, for fuck sake.
- [Joey] I just came.
(Connor laughs)
- All right.
- Joey does this every time.
He tries to spread around
the fucking Apex virus to everyone.
- Yeah, I do, it's a great game.
- The world's most deadly virus.
- Top ten deadly virus'.
(paranormal music)
- (laughs) Wait a minute,
what were you doing?
- (mumbles) Just crawled behind us.
- [Joey] What the fuck was that?
- [Connor] How's it going Joey?
Walk us through what's going on.
- Just secured the motherboard in.
- [Connor] Motherboard is secured.
- [Garnt] All right, so
that's completely secure,
just under an hour.
You're on a very good pace.
Tell us your thought process,
because Joey is now the water cooler.
It looks very, very daunting, doesn't it?
Because I know that I have to
use the thermal paste on that,
and then stick it on and then secure it.
What is this back plate that
we were just talking about?
Is it this, is this the back plate?
What is this?
- [Garnt] Okay, the
instruction manual is...
- It says installing the mounting bracket.
But...
- [Garnt] Uh huh.
Garnt fucked up here
because he installed the cooler on first,
instead of the radiator.
Should I attach the radiator first?
- [Connor] It's up to you Joey,
you can do it in any order you like.
- Just tell me the fucking right answer.
- On a scale of one to
Lego, how fun is this?
- One.
- [Connor] (chuckles)
This is not fun at all?
- No.
- [Connor] Is it not fun learning though?
- It's fun learning, but
I think I would prefer...
There are more optimal learning
environments than this.
- [Connor] I think this is
literally trial by fire.
- This is very much trial by fire.
The CPU gets very hot, Joey.
Very, very hot.
And if it doesn't cool
down, it's going to break
and overheat.
- [Joey] If it hasn't already.
- I'm sure there's no breakage.
- [Joey] How much am I suppose to put on?
- Like a pea size, imagine a pea.
- Yeah.
- A tiny amount, not much,
just a little sliver.
- [Joey] In the middle?
- Yeah, a little bit, not too much.
(popping noise)
- [Joey] Geez, this is
really tight on there.
That looks pretty good to me.
- Joey's going to secure these screws in,
make sure you get a nice, tight fit.
That way that CPU isn't going anywhere,
it won't leave me like my wife did.
(comical drums)
- [Joey] There's a lot of wires here.
- Yep, there is.
- [Joey] I don't know where to put them.
- [Connor] You can route
them through the back.
- [Garnt] Joey, let me
give you the advice,
I am the wiring expert here.
(Connor laughs)
- You're a wiring expert.
Is that an arrow?
- [Garnt] What you rather be doing Joey,
building this PC or playing Apex?
- Building this PC.
- [Garnt] Joey's just finding
different screws to screw in.
and hoping to God that
one of them actually fits.
- [Joey] I actually can't
find the fucking screws.
- All right, do you need help Joey?
- [Joey] I don't, can I
see which screws they were?
- All right, I'll go help Joey.
- [Connor] These boys are
figuring out to screw in the fan.
I normally when I build my PCs,
I normally have little
bolts to separate them,
to separate which ones are which.
- [Garnt] Twist it out.
- [Joey] Oh okay.
- [Garnt] Bruh.
- He literally just fucked up.
- I'm sorry Joey.
- [Joey] Oh my God.
He dropped the screw in here.
- All right, good luck Joey, good luck.
- [Joey] What the...
- [Garnt] Good luck.
- Just put it in and hope for the best,
yeah great advice mate.
(group laughs)
- [Connor] The salt is such great content.
- Oh okay, got it.
It's this way.
(Garnt cheers)
- He got it, yeah, let's go.
Sydney is gonna come commentate with me.
This is a thing that Garnt does,
I don't know anyone else who names PCs.
He told you, "Sydney,
you have to name it."
- Yeah.
- Is that what he said?
- Yeah, he's like, "It's your
baby, you have to name it."
- [Garnt] It's like naming
your Pokemon, right?
You have to.
- Yeah, it's my baby.
- I don't think you're
supposed to name PCs,
I don't think that's a normal thing.
- Well, do you not name your PC?
- No, never.
- [Joey] It's just machine number one.
- C-Dog PC, I think they
call it on the thing.
- What a sad name for your computer.
- [Garnt] That's no fun.
- It's not supposed to
fun, it's just what it is.
- You built it, it
wouldn't exist without you.
(group laughs)
- It's not breathing.
- It's breathing Connor, it has fans.
- Not like you, oh, got them.
- [Joey] I guess I should just start
putting in the graphics card now.
Is everything plugged in
where it needs to go into, you think?
- Well, the thing is,
I don't know what's
supposed to plug into where.
What is Joey doing right now?
Sydney, can you walk us
through what he's doing?
- [Sydney] He's putting
in the graphics card.
- [Connor What step is he doing
before he can put that in?
He's doing something.
- [Sydney] He's removing the nails
that are in the way of putting it in.
- Nails?
- I don't know, don't you
have to untwist the nails
and the fucking...
- Untwist the nails.
(high pitched laughter)
(upbeat ringtone)
- [Joey] That is not the
definition of moral support.
- Hello Chris.
- [Chris] How are you doing?
- I'm doing good.
Joey's in the middle of building a PC,
we're wondering if you have
any words of encouragement to him.
- [Chris] Well, I've never
built a bloody computer.
(Garnt and Connor laugh)
- [Garnt] This is why Chris is my boy.
- This is interesting,
you're on Twitch now, right?
I can see you on a screen,
if you touch Garnt on the shoulder for me.
I want to feel like I've got
some sort of interaction.
- Thanks Chris.
- [Chris] I want to transcend the screen.
Fucking hell, this is trippy,
for fucks sake.
(Garnt and Connor laughs)
How long's it take to
build a fucking computer?
- How long do you think
it takes to build one normally Chris?
- [Chris] I don't know,
fucking 15 minutes.
(Garnt and Connor laugh)
- Chris, help me out here,
what am I supposed to do?
What goes where mate?
- [Chris] I can barely put my shoes on,
I don't know how to
build a fucking computer.
(Garnt and Connor laugh)
- Thank you for joining us Chris,
thanks for the words of encouragement.
- Bye Chris.
- All right, see you later.
Bye.
- [Chris] Bye.
- How'd that feel Joey,
that make you feel better?
- Yeah, totally.
I just realized the CPU fan
port and the SIS fan port,
this is in the fucking way.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
Are you gonna have to unscrew?
- I'm gonna have to unscrew.
(Garnt laughs)
I'm pretty sure I said,
"Okay, I'll make sure not to do that."
(Garnt and Connor laugh)
(mystical music)
Now, if I remember correctly,
Garnt fucked up here
because he installed the cooler on first,
instead of the radiator.
So, should I attach the radiator first?
- I am gonna have to
remember my goddam hardest
to not do that now.
Otherwise that would be true monkey brain.
- Right now Joey is screwing
his radiator back in.
How many more things do you
have to plug in after this Joey?
- [Joey] I would tell
you if I had any idea.
Because apparently,
half of these wires don't
even fucking do anything.
- [Connor] Yeah, a lot of them don't.
- I genuinely don't know what
I need to plug in or not.
- [Garnt] What time are
you aiming for Connor?
- [Connor] Sub two hours.
- Sub two hours?
Well, we'll see if
Joey's computer boots up.
- [Connor] All right, start it up,
let's see if it boots.
(crickets chirping)
- Oh wait, it's not plugged in.
- [Connor] Yeah, you gotta plug it in.
(Garnt laughs)
- That slid on.
Oh, okay.
- [Connor] Oh okay, okay.
- [Garnt] Oh, okay, okay.
- [Connor] Will it boot?
(crickets chirping)
- [Garnt] Is the TV on?
- [Connor] Oh yeah, you
gotta turn the TV on.
- [Garnt] Oh, oh.
Wait for BIOS, BIOS, ready?
Time.
- [Connor] That's time, time.
(applause and cheering)
He did it.
- [Garnt] Oh God.
- [Connor] Let's go.
- [Garnt] Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
You built your first PC.
- I am never doing that again.
(group laughs)
Never in my life will
I be doing that again.
That was the worst experience of my life.
(Connor laughs)
- It's cleaner than yours,
much cleaner than yours.
- [Joey] I need to pull these
wires out a little more.
- Yeah, but look it works.
- Joey, how'd you feel?
- [Connor] Do you want a beer Joey?
(mumbled voiceover)
- Now that you've done the PC build,
would you have preferred to
play Apex for three hours,
than build a PC?
- [Connor] Yeah, which one mate?
- Just barely.
- [Connor] Apex over PC building?
- No, PC over Apex.
- [Connor] What?
No.
- Cheers Joey, you deserve it.
- That's not very (mumbles) of you Joey.
- [Garnt] Three,
two,
one.
(beep)
Go.
- Beautiful, let's go.
Delicious.
I'll start with the
CPU as Joey (laughs)...
- [Joey] Yeah, I know what to do now.
- [Garnt] Now you know all the parts Joey.
- [Joey] Now I know all the parts.
- [Garnt] This is easy-mode for Connor.
- I've got to unscrew it first.
Wait, no, what is this?
- [Garnt] You've installed
a Intel CPU before, right?
- [Voiceover] Wow.
- [Connor] There we go.
Smoothly done.
- All right, so far so good.
(Connor mumbles)
What is going on?
I thought this was gonna be a smooth run.
- This is horrible.
Was it this tough?
Can you come here Garnt?
- [Garnt] Connor, are you
asking for help already?
- No, I'm just wondering.
- All right, just because
I don't want you to
break the fucking CPU.
- [Joey] It was pretty tight
when I put it down, yeah.
- Was it this tight?
But it's lined up though.
What's going on here?
- I would commentate something right now,
but the inside of my brain is steam punk.
Where it's just cogs and steam, just psst.
And nothing is working.
- [Garnt] We'll be fine.
- Yeah, we'll be fine.
- Guys, it's not the wrong slot,
we have four RAM sticks.
- [Connor] Yeah, people are like,
think it's a dual width channel, it's not.
- Yeah, it's four RAM sticks,
so he's got it right, don't worry.
- That click never gets
old, that click is so nice.
- We've set everything up
possible to make Connor succeed,
so it's only up to him.
- Oh yeah, okay.
Yeah, my success is your success, right?
- That's how speed running works, right?
- Dude, my computer was working fine
when my monitor was connected
directly into my motherboard.
So, why am I even learning these steps?
(Garnt laughs)
- What are you going to use
your brand new gaming PC for,
Joey?
With the exclusive 3090
that is in very short stock right now.
- I don't know, render out a video.
- I'm not even gonna upload it,
I'm just gonna render it out for fun.
- I'm just gonna render
it out for fun, yeah.
- [Connor] This doesn't fit.
I don't know what's happening here.
I'm trying to get the standoff back in,
but it doesn't fit.
And none of the ones in the box
are big enough to go in this hole.
I don't really know what to do.
- Have you tried every screw?
- Yeah, but I can't get
the standoff back in now,
because this is attached to the thermal.
So it won't go back in,
unless I put it back through.
But even then, I don't think it...
- Joey, do you want to help Connor?
- [Connor] For fuck sake,
I think I got it now.
- Joey.
- [Connor] I think I got it now.
- Okay, you got it?
All right.
- [Connor] This one isn't
small enough to go in.
- There's one screw that comes with it.
- [Connor] Yeah, I've
got three screws here,
and they're all the same size.
And they're the only ones
that are single screws.
- Yeah, that's it.
That's the one, I'm pretty sure.
- [Connor] Well, I'll try it again,
but I don't think it's gonna work.
(Garnt laughs)
Having fun there laughing at me?
- Yeah, kind of.
- [Connor] Fuck you.
- Trash Taste versus
screws, who would win?
I would like to say
that Connor also does have
an Engineering degree.
Like me.
- Yeah, I'm the only one
without an Engineering degree.
- Joey had the least
problem with screws apparently.
- [Joey] You should have one
long screw and short screw.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] And then to actually
screw down the (mumbles) too,
there should be a silver,
a small silver screw.
- Yeah, I've got three
here and none of them fit.
- [Joey] Well, they should.
- Can you actually show me?
Because I'm gonna be here
all day at this point.
I actually don't know.
- [Garnt] Joey the experienced
computer builder...
- I think, yeah.
- Can help Connor.
- What, in here?
- Yeah.
I literally put that in, it doesn't go in.
- Really?
- Yeah, watch this.
- [Joey] Yeah, well it
should be like that.
- [Garnt] Welcome to the world
where Joey helps kind of build a PC.
- [Joey] You have to push it down.
- [Garnt] (chuckles)
We've seen it all chat,
we've seen it all.
- [Navi] Oh yeah, I did
have the same problem,
it should be the longer one.
- [Connor] Well then, what goes in here?
- [Navi] I know they did,
you're basically having
the same problem as I did.
And what I did was,
I think I just found an extra
long one from a different...
It's literally the short
screws that you have there,
the three short screws, that I used.
- Because the standoff is here.
- [Joey] How did you take that off?
- What do you mean?
It comes off because there's
nothing screwing it down.
- Why did you take it off?
- Well, no, because it comes off,
because when you take the screws.
- Oh, I never took mine off.
- No, I know, I wasn't
trying to, but you can.
- [Joey] Oh.
- No,
I know you can take it off.
There should've been something
that prevented you from
taking this off right there.
- [Connor] What?
- [Garnt] So these screws fit in here.
- [Joey] How is it that
Connor is struggling
with the part that was the easier for me?
- [Garnt] I know.
- [Joey] I put mine in fine.
- Yeah, I don't know
how we fucked this up.
- [Joey] The adhesives were
the part that fucked me up,
not this point.
- I like how Connor
used the word we here.
- Well, because none of
us know what's happened,
I fucked it up, but no
one knows what happened.
- Communism (laughs).
Guys, we.
We, we fucked up.
- Okay, I fucked this up.
But also, no one knows what I've done.
- Yeah, because I wasn't (mumbles).
I guess Connor just has to
screw down his M2 using the heat sink,
so M2 itself is not going to
be secured to the motherboard.
But the heat sink is going to
be secured to the motherboard,
I think it's still going to work.
- I just screwed in something else,
and I guess I'll just use that.
- Wait, you just screwed
in something else?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- [Garnt] What does that mean?
- [Connor] I just screwed in
another piece that I found.
- [Garnt] Screwed what piece?
- [Connor] When I just
took it out originally,
I just screwed that in.
I don't know if that's fair though,
I don't know if that's right.
- [Garnt] Hopefully Connor
doesn't need that screw later,
I don't think he will, I hope he doesn't.
- [Connor] We'll just do it,
fuck it, we'll do it this
way, I'm sure it'll work.
You wanna see the problem I'm having now?
- What?
- I actually can't get this off of this.
This is now, I can't get this off.
- Connor, you've fucked
it so much (laughs).
How have you fucked it so much?
- It's like (mumbles)...
- What have you actually done?
You literally forced the screw in.
- You're on a serious
red sprint right now,
but the run's not dead, you can come back.
- The run's not dead.
- Just do a couple of gold
splits, and you'll be good bro.
- I'm gonna sandwich this bit.
All right, that's the
memory done at least.
- [Joey] All right,
he's on to the case now.
- [Garnt] All I'm saying is Joey,
is that we didn't need a lot of help
until we got to the fucking...
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Garnt] Water-cooling part.
- Shut up.
Take that out of here, garbage.
- I've never seen someone
so offended in my life
as Joey is when someone
peels off something fast.
- You don't even enjoy it.
- [Garnt] Embrace your
inner monkey Connor.
- [Joey] Maybe pull it in.
There you go.
- [Garnt] There you go.
- Oh my God.
It could've fucking snapped.
- [Joey] Yeah, it's really
fucking tight for some reason
- Oh my God, I'm sweating
just trying to pull that shit,
oh my God.
- [Garnt] Connor, what are
you trying to figure out now?
- I'm not trying to figure anything out.
- [Garnt] What he's doing is
he's learnt from our mistakes,
and he is gonna at this point in the run,
he's gonna start plugging stuff
into the motherboard first.
- [Joey] Ah nice.
- [Garnt] And then pulling
it all into the back
to sort out later.
Which would've saved me
a lot of hassle as well.
- I've gotta figure out a way to get
some time back in this run boys.
- [Joey] Honestly.
- Gotta find a miracle,
we need a Christmas
miracle right about now.
- [Garnt] Connor, tell us your
thought process right now.
- [Joey] Yeah, what are
you doing right now?
- For some reason, I can't
get the CPU power in,
I don't really know why.
- [Garnt] The CPU power?
- Yeah, I'm trying to get these in,
but for some reason it doesn't fit.
I don't really know...
- [Joey] Is the shape
of the ports the same?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- [Joey] Because there's
a lot of single port ones,
where the shape is kind of different.
- This is all the same.
- [Joey] Why the fuck am I teaching him?
(Garnt laughs)
I don't what the fuck I'm on about.
I actually don't know
what I'm talking about,
why am I giving him advice?
- The last time Connor
read this many words,
he was probably in college.
What are you doing now Connor?
- Well, I've plugged all the
stuff from the motherboard in.
And the CPU's in, and...
Everything is gonna be plugged
in right now is plugged in.
Now I'm just gonna go
back to do the other part.
- [Garnt] You doing the fans right now?
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] I can't believe
you're not on path with 15 minutes Connor.
Chris is gonna have some words with you.
- Yeah, shit, I've disappointed Chris
and his legendary 15 minute PC build.
Linus is crying at the thought.
These fucking cables
are so goddamn annoying.
Did you have to use one of
these for the (mumbles) fans?
- [Garnt] What are you talking about?
- For the fans, to get all
of these wires connected up.
- [Garnt] Wait, what, use what?
- Come here as I explain to you.
- I was explaining to Connor
how the right way to connect this up.
Basically saving him a bunch of time,
because I was explaining to him
that what fucked me over
was realizing that this
doesn't connect to anything.
- Yeah, and I realized that
there's no where this could go.
- Yeah.
- This one can't go anywhere.
- Why the fuck would they do that?
What's wrong with them?
What the fuck?
- No, it's because in case you need
to connect to another fan.
- [Connor] So you didn't connect
to any of these CPU fans?
- [Garnt] No.
- What?
Ah fuck, I plugged in the
CPU thing the wrong way.
No, wait, did I?
- [Garnt] I don't think so.
Guys, I don't think Connor's
gonna make the sub two hour run.
- We lost the sub two hours boys,
I let you down on that.
- [Joey] It's okay though,
you can still get the dub,
you're still in the dub.
- But I'm still gonna get us the dub guys.
- [Joey] All right, here
we go, graphics card.
- [Garnt] Oh finally, the chunky boy.
- [Joey] The chunky
boy's about to come in,
then you can do the split.
- [Garnt] Here we go guys, we're
at the last, final stretch.
- [Joey] The final stretch,
we are currently at 2:12.
Connor has roughly 15 minutes to finish.
- [Joey] I reckon it's
gonna be fucking close.
It's either he's just gonna make it,
or, he's just not gonna make it.
- [Garnt] Okay, all this depends
on if it boots up
correctly the first time.
- [Joey] Yeah, that's if it
boots up correctly the first time.
If it doesn't then we're gonna keep going.
I think it'll boot up the first time.
- [Garnt] I think it'll
boot up the first time.
- [Joey] I think he can
continue the streak.
So far the GPUPS and the wiring split
are both gold, you
literally clipped through.
He clipped through...
He clipped through, he did a wire clip.
- [Connor] Can we just
admire my cable management.
- [Joey] Oh dude, it's clean as fuck.
- [Connor] Hopefully this fucking works,
otherwise I'm gonna cry.
- [Joey] Here we go,
it's the moment of truth.
- [Garnt] Okay, go.
- Three,
two,
one.
- [Joey] Oh, there's a light.
- No, what's going on?
- [Joey] No, hold on,
that same thing happened to me as well.
- [Garnt] Patience monkey, patience.
- [Joey] The same thing happened to me.
Press the power button again.
- (gasps) Why's it not working?
- [Joey] Wait, can you
flick the power on, maybe?
- Wait, is the CPU...
- [Garnt] Oh no.
- [Connor] I can see it's not in properly.
I'm gonna push it in.
- [Joey] It's not the first time.
- [Garnt] Come on Connor,
15 minutes, you got this.
- [Joey] Come on mate, you got it.
- [Garnt] You got it Connor.
- [Joey] Here we go.
It's gonna come down to this, here we go.
- The red light's on.
- [Joey] Red lights on, and go.
(fizzling)
- No, why's it not working?
(Garnt laughs)
- [Garnt] Oh no, Connor.
- [Joey] Connor.
Connor.
- [Garnt] Connor.
- You fucking jinxed it.
- [Garnt] Connor, how?
Connor, we were two for two.
How could you Connor?
- [Joey] Why did you break the streak bro?
- [Garnt And Joey] You
were the chosen one.
- Press the red button on the motherboard.
- [Garnt] No, don't press the
red one on the motherboard.
- [Joey] This is the most
Connor moment of all time.
- [Garnt] Wait, the core's
not turning on though.
- [Joey] Wait, look at the screen.
- [Garnt] Wait, wait, wait.
- [Joey] Is it about to be time?
It should appear soon.
- [Garnt] This is pogging chat.
- [Joey] Here we go.
- [Garnt] Here we go.
- [Joey] Here we go, come
on man, get to the bios.
- [Garnt] Oh okay, steady on.
- [Joey] Bios.
- [Group] Yeah!
(group applaud)
- Oh my God, I fucking (mumbles) it,
don't scare me like that, what the fuck?
- [Joey] GG.
- [Garnt] GG.
- [Joey] Final time, 2:27:52.
That's a Trash Taste record,
you beat Garnt's time by ten minutes.
The cable management is clean as fuck.
- [Garnt] That is clean cable management.
(Sydney laughs)
- What are you talking about?
Shut the fuck up up there.
- It definitely looks the most
clean out of all three of us.
- We should've made it cleaner though,
but we'll do that.
- [Joey] For sure.
- Hey man, you did it, we did it.
- Guys.
We won.
- We won.
- We won guys.
- [Connor] Mother fuckers I'm
never gonna live that down.
(Garnt laughs)
- It was our failures, it was our success.
- To be fair Connor, your success
was built on our failures.
- Shut the fuck up.
Were my mistakes built on your failures?
- [Garnt] Tell me where I'm wrong Connor.
- [Joey] He stood on
the shoulders of giants.
- (mumbles) Is my mistakes yours,
and your mistake, is that what
you're trying to say Garnt?
- How was your build three experience.
- Horrible.
Nah, realistically,
I probably won't do it again for a while,
but at least now I can say,
"I've builT a fucking PC.
- At least now you can
say you've built a PC
that can run Apex.
- Yeah.
(Garnt laughs)
That can run the games
that I want to play.
- That can theoretically run Apex.
- Thank you very much to Gigabyte AORUS
for sponsoring us.
- Big shout out to Gigabyte AORUS.
- Giving us these lovely,
lovely gaming computers.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much
for the 3090.
I don't know when I would've
got one without the stream.
- I don't think I every would've got one.
Absolute fucking legends.
And thank you guys
for tuning in to the
entire streaming show.
- Thank you to Ashley.
There, I didn't forget her this time.
- We'll give you a whole
pizza slice tonight.
- We will reward you a whole pizza.
No, you don't deserve it Ashley, sorry.
- [Garnt] Wow, all right.
- There's one more challenger left,
and that's Chris.
- [Garnt] Oh my God, we gotta
get Chris on to build a pc.
- Chris' 15 minute PC
build, prove it Chris.
- [Garnt] Chris' 15 minute BPC build.
- Thank you so much for watching,
if you enjoyed this please let us know
what other challenges we
could maybe do in the office,
we'd love to hear what you think.
- Yeah, we have a lot more
space to work with now.
- Yeah, we have a ton more room.
- There was no way we could do this stream
in the old office.
- No way.
- Because we would've been
cramped around this table,
and we'll see you guys
in hopefully a much nicer
looking upload stream.
- I guess, the next time
you'll see our faces is this weekend.
- (mumbles) True.
- All right, cue the Trash Taste intro.
- All stand for the National Anthem.
- Now check this out.
(mellow music)